eine insel im pazifik hier wurden der
us-armee seltsame unterirdische anlagen
zum verhängnis
das japanische militär befestigte so
viele höhlen und tunnel wie möglich als
die alliierten streitkräfte eintrafen
erwartete sie ein blutiger empfangen
ein verfallenes irisches gefängnis hier
brachen insassen nicht nur aus sondern
auch ein
hierher kamen viele schwerverbrecher
darauf war die einrichtung nicht
ausgelegt ein riesiger gebäudekomplex in
frankreich mit explosiver vergangenheit
niemand weiß genau was passiert ist
alles verschwand mit einem großen knall
war es ein unfall oder sabotage
und eine spanische geisterstadt in der
amerikanische freiheitskämpfer für ihre
ideale in die schlacht zogen
[Musik]
die inschriften sind der schlüssel zur
lösung des rätsels
[Musik]
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit
einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur noch
schatten ihrer selbst
zeit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
im westlichen pazifik auf der
japanischen insel oshima bieten düstere
ihnen einen merkwürdigen anblick
die insel sieht ungewöhnlich aus sie ist
vollkommen flach nur in ihrer mitte
erhebt sich ein einsamer berg
von oben wirkt sie wie ein
flugzeugträger
es gibt auch drei landebahnen auf
den alten rollbahnen wächst unkraut
durch risse im asphalt
es ist nicht ersichtlich von wem sie
genutzt wurden
in der nahegelegenen stadt findet sich
darauf ein hinweis
eines der gebäude passt nicht so recht
ins einundzwanzigste jahrhundert es
zeigt kampfspuren und hat riesige löcher
worten im untergrund sind noch
mysteriöser
es gibt hier viele natürliche höhe
einige davon eignet sich perfekt als
verteidigungs post
sie sind gut geschützt von außen ist
nicht zu erkennen dass hinter den
eingängen ein riesiger komplex
welche verbindung besteht zwischen den
stillgelegten startbahnen den zerstörten
gebäude und den unterirdischen höhlen
[Musik]
diese entkernte betonhülle in der
heutigen stadt ist das einzige bauwerk
der insel das den zweiten weltkrieg
überstanden hat
fremdenführer tamara kam ich weiß was
hier einmal war es
sind die überreste des städtischen
pfandhauses
es wurde vor dem krieg aus beton gebaut
das einzige erhaltene gebäude ist das
pfandhaus
es war vergleichbar mit einer bank
musste also stabil gebaut sein
trotzdem wurde es schwer beschädigt
ganz klar wurde hier gekämpft
die großen löcher stammen von
artilleriebeschuss
die kleinen von gewehrfeuer
sie mal liegt 1600 kilometer von tokio
entfernt und ist teil des japanischen
archipel der
pazifik hier nahe dem japanischen
festland war ein hart umkämpftes gebiet
die insel hatte militärische bedeutung
von den langen startbahn thema konnten
flugzeuge direkt über den pazifik
abheben
es war leicht zu starten und zu landen
und der flughafen war groß und sicher
während des zweiten weltkriegs gehören
diese nun überwucherten flugfelder zu
den größten asiens die japaner haben sie
gebaut um ihre expansion im pazifik
voranzutreiben doch 1944 müssen sie ihre
strategie ändern
die japaner erkannten dass sie noch die
mittel hatten die amerikaner auf 2 also
gingen sie den schlachten auf dem
pazifik zunehmend aus dem weg gruben
sich ein sie verschanzten sich
unterirdisch
die amerikaner wollen die kontrolle über
den flugplatz von china übernehmen
fehlte ihnen eine zwischenstation vom
amerikanischen festland
über hawaii über den pazifik hinweg bis
nach japan um dann die japanischen
hauptinseln einnehmen
die insel ist der ideale landeplatz für
schwere militärische ausrüstung
sie ist umgeben von flachen strecken das
ist auch günstig
denn überall rund um die insel findet
man eingänge zu kleinen höhlen
sie liegen unter dem flachen stein
plateau dass die insel bedeckt
nur in ihrer mitte erhebt sich der
bergbau sugiyama
die insel bietet ideale natürliche
voraussetzungen für ihre verteidigung
von der erhebung in ihrer mitte kann man
sie in alle richtungen schützen
[Musik]
und die japaner wissen wie genau man sie
am besten schützt
den amerikanern so schwer wie möglich
machen zu landen dafür setzen sie auf
artillerie
um die insel selbst zu verteidigen
hatten sie infanterie soldaten
stationiert die allerdings
vergleichsweise schlecht ausgerüstet
waren die
japaner zerstören die landebahnen
errichten blockhäuser und verlegen
landminen
doch vor allem nutzen sie alle vorteile
des suzuki java unter den kalkstein berg
liegen zahllose tunnel und höhlen durch
die sich die japaner ungesehen bewegen
können sie verstärken die eingänge zu
den tunneln bauen maschinengewehr posten
und befestigen die hüllen
manche sind drei stockwerke hoch und
bieten freies sichtfeld über die insel
sie befestigten so viele höhen und
tunnel wie möglich als die alliierten
streitkräfte eintrafen erwartete sie ein
blutiger entfernt
die zivilbevölkerung versteckt sich in
den höhlen an der küste für einheimische
wie tamara k mich sind diese orte noch
heute wichtig
das ist eine heilige stätte auf china
während des kriegs versteckten sich hier
viele menschen
die insel wurde vom meer aus mit
mörsergranaten geschossen und hier macht
sie davor sicher
die amerikanischen streitkräfte ahnen
nicht was unter der erde vor sich geht
als sie schließlich an landen sind sie
nicht auf den unsichtbaren feind
vorbereitet
am 16 april 1945 ist es soweit
die amerikaner haben während des
gesamten zweiten weltkriegs amphibische
operationen durchgeführt
doch tausende japanische soldaten
beobachten vom busse pro jahr aus jede
ihrer bewegungen
bei ihrem vorstoß auf die stadt stehen
die amerikaner unter dauerbeschuss und
sie können zivilisten nicht von soldaten
unterscheiden
bei der schlacht griffen auch zivilisten
zur waffe
einige sollten mit gewehren kämpfen aber
sie benutzten hauptsächlich granaten
die amerikaner kommen nur langsam voran
und erleiden unerwartet herbe verluste
sie müssen den juso pro jahr einnehmen
der hinter der stadt liegt
der bekannte us kriegsreporter arni pall
ist bei der erbitterten schlacht dabei
war ein amerikanischer zeitungsreporter
der das us-militär leidenschaftlich
unterstützt
er war ein kriegsberichterstatter mit
engen kontakt zu den gsv
ist mit den soldaten nahe der stadt
unterwegs als ein scharfschütze ihn in
den kopf trifft
er ist sofort tot
wie für ihn typisch war mit dem soldaten
an der front also getötet wurde
das macht die amerikaner nur noch
entschlossener die insel einzunehmen
hinter dem gedenkstein für erni paul
steht ein weiterer zeuge der heftigen
kampfhandlungen die ruine des
pfandhauses
[Musik]
das gebäude hatte keine strategische
bedeutung aber es gerät ins kreuzfeuer
sie legten es auf ihrem weg zum
japanischen hauptquartier in schutt und
asche
schließlich nehmen die amerikaner den
gozo koyama 1
doch für die einwohner von sind die
schrecken des krieges damit noch nicht
vorbei
das japanische militär trägt hatte der
bevölkerung ein dass die amerikaner
wilde tiere seien und niemand die
invasion überleben wollen
handgranaten wurden an die menschen
verteilt
sie sollten sich lieber selbst töten als
sich zu ergeben
in den höhlen nehmen sich hunderte
zivilisten das leben
doch in denia tia höhle glaubt keiner
der propaganda
viele starben in den höhlen
aber diese höhle hier wurde von einer
solchen tragödie verschont
nach einem sechstägigen kampf haben die
amerikaner in china schließlich
eingenommen
fast 5000 japaner und mehr als 1000
amerikanische soldaten sind dabei
getötet haben
manche glauben die standhafte
verteidigung der insel durch die japaner
habe die usa dazu gebracht die
atombomben abzuwerfen die den krieg im
pazifik beenden ob das nun stimmt oder
nicht china hat noch einen auftritt in
der geschichte
am ende des krieges reisten die japaner
von hier aus auf die philippinen
die japanische delegation steckt hier in
ein amerikanisches flugzeug fliegt nach
manila und stimmt dort den
friedensbedingungen zu
wir alle wissen dass sich die japaner
auf der uss missouri in der bucht von
tokio general macarthur ergaben
auch die eigentliche kapitulation fand
hier auf dem flugfeld stadt
fast vergessene teil der geschichte
[Musik]
heute erinnert kaum noch etwas an den
blutigen kampf um die china doch die
erinnerung an tausende soldaten und
zivilisten die hier starben lebt weiter
dieser ort ist eine der wenigen die noch
in den krieg erinnern nicht nur auf
china sondern in ganz okinawa wir halten
ihn sorgfältig
in der keltischen see bewacht eine
ansammlung von gebäuden irlands größten
hafen
dass diese insel hatte eine ganz
besondere lage
windig und an gelegen
die trägen zäune und mauern sie strahlen
sicherheit und stärke aus
ich würde das war ganz klar eine festung
aber hier muss noch etwas anderes
passiert sei
dieser bereich ist dunkel und still vor
den fenstern sind es
die dunkelheit verschlingt einen je
tiefer man gering
es ist wie in einer zeitkapsel einige
bereiche sind mehrere jahrhunderte alt
andere wirken als gäbe es sie erst seit
20 jahren
ein langes gebäude in der mitte des
komplexes könnte hinweise liefern
es gibt klare anzeichen dafür dass es
hier einmal gebrannt hat etwas
verheerendes muss hier passiert sein
die ausgebrannten ruine werfen fragen
auf was ist hier passiert
das ist zwar kein cent die insel liegt
in irdischen gewässern doch die
verteidigungsanlagen wurden vor über 200
jahren von den briten errichtet
der historiker tom o'neil hat früher
hier gearbeitet
[Musik]
die briten bauten das vor weil sie
befürchteten irland könne von feinden
eingenommen und als basis genutzt werden
um das britische festland anzugreifen
die baukosten entsprechen heute rund 84
millionen dollar
es war ein bedeutendes projekt der bau
begann 1806 und dauerte 60 jahren auf
neun hektar entstand eine hochmoderne
militäranlage
von hier sieht man wie gut durchdacht
die ganze anlage ist das vor ist sehr
gut befestigt
die gebäude sind sternförmig angeordnet
und von tiefen gräben umgeben so konnte
das vor in jede richtung verteidigt
werden
das zahlte sich aus kein feind griff die
insel an
den weiß hier nicht immer friedlich
jahre später wurde es von innen heraus
angegriffen
das vor diente nicht nur der
verteidigung es gibt noch eine zweite
geschichte
vergitterte fenster
sicherheitszäune und verstärkte tore
die briten setzten die festung ein um
macht über die ihren auszuüben
[Musik]
gelegen auf einer insel mit hohen mauern
und hervorragende rundumsicht eignet
sich das vor perfekt als gefängnis
1845 während der großen hungersnot in
irland wird das vor zu einem zuchthaus
für arme
die menschen waren verzweifelt man hier
ließen sich sogar absichtlich verhaft
nur um ein essen zu kommen die lage ist
für so viele menschen derart
aussichtslos dass immer mehr hier
inhaftiert werden
zusätzlich dienst bei keilen den briten
auch als zwischenstation für verurteilte
die in strafkolonie verschifft werden
sollen
es kamen immer mehr häftlinge an einem
punkt waren es bis zu zweieinhalb
tausend menschen damit wurde es zu einem
der größten gefängnisse der welt in
dieser zeigt
nach ende der hungersnot wird die
haftanstalt 1883 geschlossen doch nicht
für lange
1916 lehnen sich die iren gegen die
militärische unterdrückung durch die
briten auf wieder spielt dass vor eine
wichtige rolle
des irdischen
unabhängigkeitskrieges diente es wieder
als gefängnis einige der zellen sehen
noch genau so aus wie damals
[Musik]
wurden die republikanischen kämpfer
gefangen gehalten hier haben sie gelebt
geschlafen gegessen und ihre tage
verbracht
bewacht werden sie von britischen
soldaten
feindseligkeiten sind da nicht zu
vermeiden
es gab große spannungen zwischen den
häftlingen und den wächtern feinde war
irischen kämpfer hatten ja versucht
vertreter der königlichen streitkräfte
zu töten
einige berühmte revolutionäre tanzen den
briten regelrecht auf der nase herum
es gab hier einen besonders
einflussreichen insassen namens tom
belohnt er hat der baracken der
britischen armee zerstört und stand ganz
oben auf der liste der meistgesuchten
männer am weihnachtsmorgen 1920 ist er
dann in cork verhaftet worden
malone ist kommandeur der irisch
republikanischen armee
mit hilfe des katholischen gefängnis
priesters gelingt es ihm aus der
haftanstalt zu fliehen so wird er als
putin irlands bekannt
seine kameraden müssen bis zur
unabhängigkeit
1921 hier ausharren
[Musik]
wie die modernen zellentüren vermuten
lassen war das noch nicht das ende des
gefängnisses aufs ball keinen
1985 wurde das vor wieder als gefängnis
verwendet weil die verbrechensrate
sprunghaft angestiegen war musstest
island einige der zusätzlichen häftlinge
aufnehmen
dieses mal betreiben was die iren selbst
dieser bereich hier wurde 1985
modernisiert
25 10 für je vier bänke platz für
insgesamt 102
andere blöcke sind weniger gut gesichert
eigentlich sollten nur insassen mit
geringem sicherheitsrisiko naspa kein
entkommen dann hätte es auch keine
probleme gegeben
wenn gefängnisdirektorin häftlinge in
andere anstalten abschieben können
wollen sie natürlich als erstes die
unruhestifter loswerden
es kamen viele schwerverbrecher darauf
war die einrichtung nicht ausgelegt
hinweise auf die folgen finden sich vor
allem in einem teil der haftanstalt
man sieht die spuren des feuers die
schäden die zerstörten fenster man kann
sich denken dass das letzte kapitel
dieses ortes ein sehr gewaltsames von
spike island das vor dass zum gefängnis
wurde ist nicht darauf vorbereitet so
viele schwerverbrecher unterzubringen in
einem der zellen blogs kommt es
schließlich zum aufstand tom o'neil ist
damals einer der wächter und erlebt das
chaos hautnah mit
das hier war
1985 eine der schlafsäle
am 31 august kam es kurz vor mitternacht
zur revolte
die häftlinge rissen den holzboden auf
und zündeten ihn an dann tragen sie die
hölzernen türen ein und flohen
neben sie kamen bis zum 4 aber nicht
weiter der vorteil einer gefängnisinsel
weil sie nicht weg konnten brachen sie
in das gefängnis ein und zerstörten dort
alle
doch das gut befestigte ehemalige
britische vor ist nicht so leicht
einzunehmen
die insassen brechen mit einem bagger
die türen auf
es war ein bild der verwüstung kopierer
wurden umgeworfen farbeimer aufgerissen
und die farbe verschüttet ihnen ging es
nur um zerstörung
der aufstand wird niedergeschlagen
danach dienst bike island noch weitere
20 jahre als haftanstalt
das gefängnis wurde umgebaut und besser
gesichert sie hatten daraus gelernt
2004 wurde es dann endgültig geschlossen
vor allem weil die kosten zu hoch waren
[Musik]
fast 200 jahre war die insel für die
öffentlichkeit nicht zugänglich
heute ist sie eine touristenattraktion
ihre bewegte geschichte soll für
nachfolgende generationen erhalten
werden
sie bietet momentaufnahmen von
entscheidenden punkten in der irischen
geschichte
und von einem konflikt der diese
nachhaltig geprägt und viel gewalt
hervorgebracht hat
[Musik]
überreste einer spanischen geisterstadt
zeugen von ihrer religiösen
vergangenheit
jahrhundertelang menschen gewohnt
mindestens seit dem mittelalter
diese kleinen dörfer in den spanischen
bergen schafften es immer nur gerade so
zu überleben
das auffälligste gebäude ist eine kirche
war das zentrum der gemeinde
sie ist nur noch eine ruine
das dorf ist stark beschädigt
manche gebäude wurden offenbar
niedergebrannt viele
wurden von artillerie feuer zerstört die
mauern sind gezeichnet von
granateneinschlägen und einschusslöcher
wer kämpfte hier gegen wen
es sind immer wieder in schriften zu
finden sie sind teil des schlüssels zur
lösung des rätsels und dann stößt man
auf eine gedenktafel für robert hail
mary man
das klingt nicht besonders spanisch
müssen die amerikaner irgendetwas damit
zu tun gehabt haben
eine gruppe freiheitskämpfer wurde hier
ihre ideale beraubt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dieser ort heißt corba debré heute ist
nur noch wenig von der einst
florierenden gemeinde übrig in der simon
tanjas vater in den 1920 er geboren
wurde
[Musik]
das hier ist eine der hauptstraßen
wir standen früher über häuser
man sieht noch die reste des
kopfsteinpflasters
das ist das fundament des geburtshauses
meines vaters
damals leben die menschen in kuba wie
schon seit jahrhunderten die macht geht
von kirche und großgrundbesitzern aus
die erste kirche wurde hier im 13
jahrhundert gebaut
das zentrum des dorfes
die leute die damals in diesem kleinen
spanischen dorf lebten waren arm
aber sie hatten einen starken glauben
und sahen sich selbst als untertan einer
katholischen monarchie
die beschädigungen an der kirche deuten
darauf hin dass das beschauliche leben
irgendwann zu ende gewesen sein muss
1931 will die neue linke regierung die
katholischen grossgrundbesitzer
entmachten
aber damit sind nicht alle einverstanden
[Musik]
es gab eine rechtsextreme
militaristische bewegung die glaubte
spanien
[Musik]
hochrangige offiziere superreiche und
vertreter der katholischen kirche
schlossen sich zur nationalistischen
bewegung zusammen
angeführt vom general francisco franco
verüben die nationalisten 1936 einen
putsch
es ist der beginn des spanischen
bürgerkriegs der auch in korea
ausgefochten wird
hier sieht man die rest einiger
historischer inschriften
dort steht ein genommen von der cmt
die spanische abkürzung für die
nationale vereinigung der arbeit
das war damals eine anarchistische
widerstandsgruppe
die anarchisten kämpfen gegen francos
faschisten eine ihrer einheiten fällt in
kuba ein
als die cnt das dorf einnahmen seien die
kämpfer im christa des dorfes einen
nationalisten einen faschisten einen
fall
so brachten sie ihn um
die anarchisten ermorden ihn und seine
mitarbeiter als sie das doch wieder
verlassen ist es jedoch noch intakt
währenddessen tobt im rest des landes
ein ungleicher kampf zwischen
faschistischen nationalisten und linken
republikanern
[Musik]
die republikaner die die regierung
bildeten kämpften auf verlorenem posten
sie bekamen weder von dem amerikanern
noch von den brücken schützenhilfe die
armee der nationalisten hingegen wurde
vom faschistischen italien und den nazis
in deutschland unterstützt
aber in den 1930 er gibt es viele junge
idealisten die bereitwillig für die
demokratie in den kampf ziehen
2800 amerikaner kämpften im spanischen
bürgerkrieg als freiwillige mit den
republikanern sie wurden bekannt als das
lincoln bataillonen
einige der berühmtesten intellektuellen
zogen in den kampf nicht hemingway
berichtete als zeitungsreporter über den
krieg und george orwell kämpfte auf
seiten der republikaner
die kämpfer des lincoln bataillons
stehen politisch links sind aber nicht
alle kommunisten
robert hellmann einer der kommandeure
des lincoln bataillons gab sein studium
auf um in den spanischen bürgerkrieg zu
ziehen
bis anfang 1938 bleibt kopierer von
schweren kampfhandlungen verschont doch
das soll sich bald ändern
wie die ruinen bis heute beweisen
[Musik]
das dorf liegt nahe des flusses ebro und
der krieg rückt schnell näher
wenn die nationalisten den ebro
einnehmen und in richtung mehr vorrücken
schlagen sie eine schneise durch das
republikanisch kontrollierte gebiet sie
wollen ihn unbedingt erobern und die
republikaner in unbedingt halten
vor kuba schließen sich merry men und
seien entkräftet das bataillon mit den
republikanern zusammen
im märz 1938 kapierten soldaten hier
ganz in der nähe von korbach
sie gehörten zu den internationalen
brigaden und waren stark geschwächt
sie waren zurückgeschlagen worden und
wollten sich hier neu formieren
marie man glaubt sich und seine männer
in dem von republikanern besetzten dorf
in sicherheit bringen zu können was er
jedoch nicht weiß ob er ist inzwischen
von den nationalisten eingenommen worden
das lincoln bataillon ist hinter die
feindlichen linien geraten ohne sich
dessen bewusst zu sein im april 1938
treffen die männer auf ein lager der
nationalisten
und sein stellvertretender offizier
wurden gefangen
soweit wir wissen wurden sie auf der
stelle erschossen
die republikaner kämpfen weiter und
erobern kopierer schließlich zurück
doch die vergeltung der nationalisten
lässt nicht lange auf sich warten
noch am selben tag begann das
bombardement es wiederholte sich fast
täglich
mussolini schickte truppen ende von
franco geführten nationalisten zu
unterstützen die deutschen entsandten
ihrem luftwaffen verband legion condor
franco wollte die republikaner durch zur
loburg schlagen und genau so war das
auch im dorf comeback
im august 1938 wird der ort jetzt wieder
in der hand der republikaner zur
zielscheibe der nationalistischen armee
hier war man etwas vom artillerie feuer
geschützt deswegen bauten einige
soldaten hier behelfsmäßige bunker
sieben löcher aus und nutzten die wände
der häuser
nach den bombern kamen tiefflieger mit
maschinengewehren
an dieser mauer sind noch die einschüsse
zu sehen
als die sogenannte ebro schlacht vorüber
ist liegt cobra in schutt und asche
da wird auch die ewige flamme genannt
nägel und andere dinge aus metall sind
geschmolzen und ihre abdrücke erhalten
geblieben sogar hier ein stift zum
öffnen einer sardinenbüchse
wenn man sich dieses dorf und die ganze
zerstörung dort anschaut sieht man die
brutal der spanische bürgerkrieg
wirklich war
1939 übernehmen die nationalisten unter
frank roth die kontrolle über spanien
der diktator herrscht fast 40 jahre lang
wie der frieden ein doch jetzt war es
eine diktatur als die dorfbewohner
zurückkehrten fanden sie nur noch ruinen
sie beugt mierdorf in der nähe neu auf
[Musik]
heute erinnert kuvert an die
freiheitskämpfer die hier ihr leben
ließen
sie wollten den faschismus aufhalten der
europa in den ruin zu treiben droht
sie boten diesen faschisten die stirn
als die regierungen dazu noch nicht
bereit waren
diese idealistischen freiwilligen in
spanien waren die ersten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im elsass nahe der deutsch-französischen
grenze liegt ein rätselhafter
gebäudekomplex mit explosiver
vergangenheit
[Musik]
im hauptgebäude sind alle fenster
zerbrochen
etwas gewaltiges muss hier passiert sein
sieht man diese seltsamen ge bilder die
alles überblicken
was auch immer hier hergestellt wurde
für den abtransport wurde einiger
aufwand betrieben
[Musik]
überwucherte gleise verlaufen über das
gelände sie wurden jahrzehntelang nicht
genutzt auf ihnen steht sogar noch ein
verlassen dazu
was war die funktion dieser verfallen
dann bauten
hier gab es etwas für das menschen
getötet hätten so wichtig und wertvoll
war
der erste hinweis findet sich in 800
meter tiefe
hier wurde nach etwas wertvollem
gegraben aber nicht nach gold diamanten
oder silber
das ist die mine caro rudolph hier wurde
ein wertvoller bodenschatz gefördert
john muss jan o hat hier einmal
gearbeitet
ich habe 30 jahre hier gearbeitet
die bedingungen waren sehr hart
mit diesem aufzug sind die arbeit
heruntergefahren hier sind wir oben am
schacht 1 erreicht 750 meter in die
tiefe
die minenarbeit war schlimm es war heiß
und denkt und traf man auf einen
gasanschluss konnte es zu einer
explosion kommen
es war gefährlich und teuer dieses
mineral zu fördern
innerhalb eines jahrhunderts des
betriebs termine sterben hier mehr als
600 menschen
welches mineral rechtfertigt so einen
hohen preis
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts war
caro rudolf einer der haupt förder
standorte für pottasche
[Musik]
pottasche ist eines der besten
düngemittel die es gibt und unter caro
rudolf ein riesiges vorkommen
die erste mine wird 1913 eröffnet um das
begehrte mineral aus dem boden zu holen
zu beginn des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
gab es eine bevölkerungsexplosion
es musste sehr schnell mehr und
ertragreichere getreide angepflanzt
werden dafür brauchte man dünger
einer seiner hauptbestandteile ist
kalium karbonat auch bekannt als
pottasche
das elsass ist schon länger zwischen
deutschland und frankreich umkämpft
die mine macht die region für beide
seiten noch begehrenswerter
[Musik]
rudolph war eine der wenigen pottasche
minen außerhalb deutschlands das machte
sie zu einem strategischen ziel
als 1914 der erste weltkrieg ausbrach
fielen die deutschen in frankreich ein
und beanspruchten das porsche vorkommen
für sich
außerdem ist pottasche auch ein
wichtiger bestandteil von schießpulver
die stillgelegten gleise führen zu den
ehemaligen schützengräben des ersten
weltkriegs über sie wurde nicht nur
pottasche transportiert
geheimdienstberichten zufolge wurde von
hier munition verschickt
1914 15 bauten die deutschen in karow
rudolf eine schmalspurbahn mit der die
munition an die front gebracht wurde
weil die mine so wichtig für die
möglichkeit der deutschen ist krieg zu
führen wollen sowohl briten als auch
franzosen sie zerstören
[Musik]
ein silvester 1915 wurde diese ganze
anlage von einer heftigen explosion
erschüttert
der gesamte komplex liegt in trümmern
die darin gelagerte munition hat die
detonation verstärkt
noch in 30 kilometern entfernung hat man
die erschütterung gespürt aber wer war
dafür verantwortlich
am naheliegendsten wäre ein luftschlag
der alliierten gewesen doch daran
glaubten die einheimischen licht
der angriff am 31 dezember hatte
symbolcharakter alle feierten
vielleicht feierten sie an diesem tag
auch einen sieg
denn für einen unfall wäre das ein
ungewöhnliches datum so etwas passiert
normalerweise eher während die
produktion läuft wir werden es nie
erfahren
[Musik]
egal aus welchem grund lange nachdem die
franzosen sie nach dem ersten weltkrieg
wieder unter ihre kontrolle gebracht
haben bleibt die mine außer betrieb
sie wurde erst 1929 wieder eröffnet dann
lief die produktion wieder auf
hochtouren weil alle welt pottasche
brauchte
aldi gebäude die auf dem gelände stehen
dienen nur einem zweck die hohe
nachfrage zu bedienen
am meisten faszinieren mich an dieser
anlage natürlich die fördertürme die
fehlt in den himmel ragen
die mine musste hunderte tonnen geröll
aus dem boden fördern es wurde mit
stahlseilen an die oberfläche gehievt
die über rollen in den türmen liefen
während der folgenden jahrzehnte werden
hier 500 millionen tonnen pottasche
gefördert
doch je tiefer gegraben wird desto
teurer wird die produktion
2003 wird schließlich der letzte schacht
stillgelegt
[Musik]
heute ist die mine verlassen
sie hat zwei weltkriege überlebt doch
die reste der maschinen und die ruinen
erzählen vor allem die geschichte der
menschen die hier gearbeitet haben
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten
andere waren einst leuchtende beispiele
für technologischen fortschritt
sie sind zeugen unserer vergangenheit
die bis in die gegenwart
überdauert haben